[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight I'll play some sense that
Harry's Truth Exposed as a pack of fibs
the prince has gone nuclear on the
British media's lies so I'm going to
call out every single one of his
Harry Megan's Infamous claims on over
Winfrey saw the royal family condemned
as a bunch of racists now they say we
didn't mean that and it was all of
course the fault of the British press
and they or did they not accuse the
Royals of racism or settle that debate
once and for all plus Harry calls
himself a feminist married to one of the
world's biggest feminists and yet in his
book he slaves women as greasy blows
some toads and villains who's Harry
another Duke of toxic masculinity
she was the villain that made her
dangerous because of the connections
that she was forging within the British
press Pat wasn't hot that was cool Pat
was small mousy
frazzled
and her hair fell greasy into her always
tired eyes
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well Canadian Rolanda welcome
to Piers Morgan uncensored first Harry
told us his truth now he's telling us
his truth about his truth because he
says we're not telling the truth about
his truth can you follow that well last
night the prince of grievance continued
his trashing tour with a nauseating
appearance on Malaysia I've had it
nauseating a lot of people may have
enjoyed it viewers who are seething
about his shabby assault on his family
in his ever-changing story should maybe
reach for the suit buckets
[Music]
I've been there since I began to grow
[Music]
thank you for bringing in the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
well the host went on to mop the corgis
he bought him a couple of keyless shots
they sort of took the Mickey out of
British Pomp and ceremony and then Harry
launched into his favorite subject which
of course is well two favorite subject
isn't it one is trashing his family the
other one's trashing the evil British
press of which I have been a leading
member for many years and once again
Harry wants to convince you that what
you have seen with your own eyes and
Herb with your own ears you haven't
actually seen and heard
without doubt the most dangerous lie
that they have told is that I somehow
boasted about the number of people that
I killed in Afghanistan my words are not
dangerous but the spin of my words are
very dangerous dangerous because it
makes you a increased Target those are
those around you that you love that is a
choice they've made
yeah actually Harry the choice was yours
you chose to reveal the number of people
that you killed in Afghanistan you chose
to describe them as chess pieces removed
from the board and it was military
leaders and servicemen some of whom
served alongside you who lined up to
condemn your choice as undignified and
dangerous never mind what I have to say
about this although my brother is a
recently retired British army colonel
and my sister married an army colonel
but another Colonel Tim Collins a
British war hero accused Harry of
turning on his military family he called
it a tragic money-making scam
is he too a dangerous spinner
or is he calling it as many people in
the military see it well Harry told
People magazine that he made that boast
for his own healing Journey there's not
much healing in this book is there a lot
of her being thrown at people at
Buckingham Palace last night he said it
was his intention when he revealed the
number of people he killed of the
Taliban to reduce the number of suicides
amongst military veterans but he never
mentioned that as the reason why he was
talking about this in his book
could it be that he's now putting a spin
on his own words because of the backlash
and that's for lies and he's very very
hot on accusing the British press of
lying well Harry's book it turns out is
chock full of little porkies
but first this is what Harry has to say
about the importance of accuracy
yes I have actually watched the car oh
yeah well it's recent stuff or or the
the older stuff uh the older stuff and
the more recent stuff yeah um do you
fact check it while you watch it
[Applause]
um
yes I do actually
which by the way by the way
another reason why it's so important
that history has it right yeah I
couldn't agree more very important the
history has it right so in the interest
of History we've done some fact checking
ourselves with the help of other
journalists around the world Harry
writes glowingly for example about his
distant grandfather King Henry VI who
founded Eaton college but actually King
Henry's lineage ended when his son died
as a childless teenager Harry says he
can't remember anything from his early
childhood he does miraculous he'll
remember his father calling him a spare
shortly after his birth he says he got
an Xbox for his 13th birthday four years
before Xboxes existed he vividly
describes receiving a phone call while
he was eaten to break the news of the
queen mother's death but the problem is
he was in in Switzerland skiing with his
family when it happened he describes
urging Megan's father Thomas to fly to
Britain to escape the media which is
confusing because it's of course the
British press who are the Rabid devils
in that case we told him leave Mexico
right now
a whole new level of harassment is about
to rain down on you so come to Britain
now Air New Zealand first class booked
and paid for by Meg yeah problem is Air
New Zealand doesn't even offer first
class tickets from Mexico to the UK in
fact he doesn't offer flight at all
from Mexico to the UK
but Harry's big lie the tallest tale of
a lot of the most damaging is of course
the claim that he and Megan never accuse
the royal family of racism
the way the British press reacted to
that was fairly typical neither of us
believe that
that comment
or that experience
or that opinion was based in racism
really
not buying it I'm afraid if that's the
truth Harry why did both of you allow
almost two years of this kind of
coverage
just the fact that there is according to
both of them this ongoing blatant racism
not only in the UK tabloid press but in
the family Megan spoke about the racism
she faced from inside and outside the
institution she said there were concerns
about the color of their Sun skin it
suggests that the institution the people
within it working and as Royals are in
some way racist our own family thought
differently of her races and a new
construct in this world for people of
color so it wasn't a complete surprise
to hear her her feelings
and just to remind everybody in December
Harry and Megan flew to New York to
receive an award from the Kennedy
foundation for their quotes heroic stand
against structural racism in the royal
family think about that for a moment an
award for something they now say they
never said
there was no racism
it was the evil British press that made
it all up
well the inference of those comments to
Oprah Winfrey was crystal clear I'll
play the clip again in a moment the
result was emphatic and predictable
Harry and Megan could have put a stop to
this racism charge at any moment in the
last two years all it would have taken
was a short statement to clarify that's
not what they meant or a few seconds of
reflection in any one of their many
hours of podcasts documentaries and
multiple television interviews but they
didn't did they they let the whole world
believe the Royals were racist
and now they say that's not what we
meant well Harry's a big fan of healing
trauma personal Journeys and therapy I'm
sure he knows what gaslighting is if he
doesn't Megan can tell him it's when you
lie and spin to treat people into
questioning their own sanity and
reasoning and that's what this is isn't
it he's trying to Gaslight all of this
into believing his truth and the what
comes out of his mouth and his wife's
mouth
is not actually what comes out of their
mouths
and that's the problem isn't it when you
choose your own version of the truth
anyway we'll get into all this today and
we're going to have people who don't
agree with me which is always the best
place to start I think with a debate I'm
joined by the black lives matter
activist Iman Ayden and the author and
friend of Prince Harry the former rugby
International James Haskell welcome to
both of you so to be sitting very
patiently there listening to me tear
into your mate am I wrong I've never
seen you in full flow actually it's
quite terrifying I was wondering what's
going to happen if you got a bit shouty
and I was trying to think can I am I
articulate enough I'm intelligent enough
to take Piers Morgan on well I have seen
you in full fly on a rugby field and you
have another way of dealing with that's
what I feel like so I think on this
balance I'll keep you just thought
violence could be the answer
look I think it's interesting because
obviously you're very invested in the in
the story I think there's a lot of
people well I'll tell you that before
you you know I just want to say the
reason I'm so personally invested I
think people know why is because I
queried a lot of these things at the
time and I for example when the when the
Oprah exchange with Meghan Markle about
racism was playable play it now so you
can remind yourselves and I'll tell you
what then happened let's watch this and
also concerns and conversations about
how dark his skin might be when he's
born
what about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like to hold it hold up there's
several minutes there are several
conversations there's a conversation
with you with Harry
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like oh
and you're not going to tell me who had
the conversation
I think that would be very damaging to
them okay compartmentalize they're
concerned that if you were to
Brown
that that would be a problem are you
saying that
I wasn't able to follow up with why but
that if that's the Assumption you're
making I think that feels like a pretty
safe one
that is the thing James I the morning
after that aired on Good Morning Britain
I came out fighting and I said I just
don't believe that I don't believe a
senior member of the royal family would
have expressed concern that if the
baby's skin color was too dark that
would be a problem and I wanted to see
the evidence I also said that when she
talked about having suicidal thoughts
and then situated with the palace spoke
to officials and they said she couldn't
get help for it I said I just can't
believe that conversation has happened I
want to see the evidence for two years
no evidence emerged it's not in his book
either of those things they don't appear
in the book of his life and now he just
casually says well we never meant it to
be racism that was the evil British
press now look I get why he hates the
Press I get it he thinks the Press
killed his mother I think a drunk driver
killed his mother and I think that she
was obsessively followed by the
paparazzi and too much so and I've
always said that but ultimately the
inquest determined it was a drunk driver
it was a predominant cause of her death
but he hates the person Because he
believes that the press conspired to
kill his mother and so I get why he
feels the way he does but that doesn't
give him license to Brand his family a
bunch of races allow two years
of this kind of onslaught headline so
damaging to the Royals reputation and
you know like you do a podcast with Mike
Tindall you know you know you know how
they all feel about this and then to
just to casually say we didn't mean that
yeah look I think when I put it like
that does part of you think even though
you're a mate no look I think I'm always
very objective about everything you know
just as the people who might expect my
friends to be objective about me you
know I definitely get things right all
the time I I saw the documentary and and
I've read only a little bit of the book
because only got it the other day I'm a
slow reader as you imagine rugby player
and and you know one of the things I've
I felt as zless celebrity right it's
incomparable to someone like Carrie I
understand how the media uh on always
hold accountable they can take things
and put their interpretation on it yeah
part of the stuff that he talked about
in his book because of the manuscript's
stolen right and a lot of this
Sensational stuff because it was so uh
out there was taken out of context yeah
but hang on I've read it all yes I
literally spent six hours on Tuesday
reading the whole thing
the point about the Taliban Revelation
for example was twofold one the British
army guy they just don't put a number on
it in public they might to each other no
I agree with that they don't do it in
public yeah you know that yeah you've
spoken to enough of them secondly
dehumanizing the enemy to a bunch of
chess pieces that again is not something
they do in public they might in the bar
yeah but they know that there is a
certain code that comes with being a
British Army uh either officer or one of
the one of the troops and you don't you
don't cross that line I mean I think I
think look you're looking at kind of
with the intense intention with the
particular details when I'm talking more
as an overarching view of saying when
someone is in his position more often
not the belief from being part of the
royal family was never complained never
explain never comment about anything
right firstly we've got to break this
this idea that they're not just a normal
family because they absolutely are
dysfunctional normal family that
everybody has well they're not a normal
family well but no because they live in
palaces they do but and the British
taxpayer pays for you they don't pay for
you and me no but when they scrape that
away because they are simply still
humans I know people think I know lots
of
them
I agree they're human beings yes so if
you if you take that to a point and in
his position you very rarely get to tell
your story without people a journalist
interviewing you so you and I are on TV
today right you think this could be
edited up and bits of it could be could
be altered or if you were right do a
written interview your interpretation is
written out it's not what actually says
so I feel that he has written this book
as a way of going look in regardless of
what happened this is what I feel and
I'm not saying whether it's true or not
I've got no comment I don't really care
to be honest with you but I'm saying
he's put this out there to go this is my
version I finally got an opportunity to
speak now whether he should have spoken
what he said was right or wrong that's
another story I just feel that people in
that position don't often get to tell
the story and I think he's done it in a
way that most of his peers and most of
his family have never had the
opportunity to do and that's I think for
me that's important because it cannot be
misinterpreted or or shouldn't be
misinter let me tell you what would
happen if they all did what he's done
the monarchy would die I agree
they would become a real-life soap opera
right it would be utterly catastrophic
for the reputation of the royal family
in the monarchy of all they did was
throwing money at each other in public
and the monarchy would die but one of
the last surviving monarchies is it is
but I think interestingly in his
particular situation with what happened
to his mother for example right and
again you know in your own words you
said you know what she hounded to the
nth degree yes yeah and and do you see
what happens with the royal family for
example that the Zeitgeist of how
popularity goes one minute one of them
is the best things in its life spread
the next one but that's why but that's
why they have to play the long game I
mean the queen mother was a great
example she never gave an interview in
order the daughter of the queen she was
absolutely of the Mantra never
complained never explain because she
just thought over time it all balances
out you get the great stuff we've had
the Jubilee but I think in the modern
and you get the negative stuff I think
just in but in the modern world right
when they were when they were sort of
when she was reigning and when the queen
mother was alive you didn't have social
media you didn't have instant comments
you didn't have 24-hour news that that
is a new feature and the problem is I
don't think it matters well I think it
does because because the way it spreads
and the nature of things like trolling
you cannot get the truth out there so
for example I follow you on Twitter you
know I'm a big fan of what you what you
you do it in lots of Parts but you're
very defensive of yourself so when
someone questions you of course you will
come out and tell the truth if I'm a
journalist I'm not a member no but but
he is also a human that I think
he's put up with a lot of rubbish so
just as you would defend yourself I
would defend myself the difference is
what he does now actually has some
weight because when for example if you
wrote an article about me in the paper
and it was wrong and I got an apology
it's page 37. if I did a video on social
media after that you you made me head uh
front page article maybe 20 people see
it yeah he has now put a like a flagpole
or a mark in the ground to say this is
my true this is my story now you can
debate it to the end's degree whether
that's factually correct but I think
that's just important for him let me
bring it bring him on look you know it's
good to have a friend of Harry on to
give the other side of it and I know
that I'm sure a lot of his friends feel
that way my issue really is about this
incendiary racism charge because to me
it was very clear what they were saying
in that Oprah Winfrey there was no
ambiguity on that and I had a vested
interest because I queried it and as a
result of querying it I lost my job
right and as a result of Sharon Osborne
supporting my right to just have an
opinion she lost her job for backing a
racist sympathy advisor me because I
wouldn't believe these allegations that
made me erase it so I do feel personally
invested in this you and I have debated
this issue of racing the Royals before
what are you making of this it's an
extraordinary climb down I know right
um I have to preface my statement by
saying this so I I watched you yesterday
and the day before I watched you be
gaslit by two ignorant black women I
actually felt quite sorry for you so I
want to say welcome to the club Piers
Morgan how does it feel to be gaslit
when claiming something is racism how's
it feel it's annoying right it's
annoying it's very annoying I saw your
face I don't mind I can take it I'm a
big boy uh I I don't mind it what I do
like I like getting to the truth yes
which is not my version of it it's not
Prince Harry's it's not Meghan markle's
it's not even your version of the truth
truth should be sacrificed and it seems
to me we've moved from the royal family
we're racist about the skin color of our
baby to we never meant to say anything
about them being racist yes and I'm
sorry you can't do that and let that
hang there for two years with all of
them under suspicion so that was never
the issue so I'll just make it nice and
clear they made a claim of racism
because the statement itself is racist
they knew it then they knew it now and
they also knew how it was going to be
perceived and I just want to touch on
this point in terms of this racism
versus unconscious bias issue if you
wouldn't mind appears so what Harry
tried to say is that in order to stop
your unconscious bias from manifesting
into racism you have to be anti-racist
right so that equation that he offered
is accurate he just made a mistake in
terms of how he explained it and he
contradicted himself in the process so I
just want to make this clear for all of
your viewers and for yourself and for
your lovely self as well
unconscious bias is a feeling or an
inclination that you didn't know you had
so it's a feeling but you have to start
at the top of the equation so number one
is Prejudice Prejudice is based on
thought that comes first bias is based
on feeling that's come second racism is
based on Behavior Behavior as a result
of your thoughts and feelings that comes
last so the minute the individual
vocalized their concern about archery
skin color it was no longer let me just
finish we don't even know this is
finished but let me just finished the
minute it was vocalized and I agree with
that I'm not disputing on that point
I'll get to that point the minute it was
localized it was no longer a thought
which is Prejudice it was no longer a
feeling which is biased it became a
behavior and a behavior is racism so
therefore if we take obviously what they
said literally
that person was being right but here's
my problem with all this yeah I don't
disagree with any of you just said right
that's a perfect description of where we
are with all the nuances
there will be lots of people who don't
even know what unconscious buyers means
right so to have it explained is useful
uh for this debate because he talks
about it a lot now but you can also be
an unconscious idiot yes and I think
this is where I would lay the charger
Harry he may not have even realized what
they were getting into here but remember
she said that these comments were made
when she was pregnant he said it was
when they just got together that's a
two-year Gap they couldn't even get the
year right that this comments supposed
to be made we never got told who was
supposed to have said them we never got
told the context not a word of it
appears in his book and I'm sorry I am
as cynical today as I was the morning
after and it may have cost me my job but
I have not seen a shred of evidence that
any member of the royal family was
racist about their baby not a shred and
now it looks to me like they've climbed
down completely and hope we all just
move on and forget it okay so what I'm
will say is I will happily and humbly
accept the defeats when it comes to them
being called Liars they have proven
themselves to be Liars however
black lives matter out of this is it not
incredibly damaging to the cause of
trying to get rid of racism in society
yeah and I don't think Britain's a
racist country but we still have racists
in it that in our efforts to try and
expunge this country of all racism it's
not very helpful in the sixth in line to
the throne throws a race grenade and his
wife does at the royal family and it
turns out not to be true well I have to
say so like I said I will concede that
they are liars however it does not
negate the fact that Harry was bullied
and harassed by the media it does not
negate
I'm not I'm not disputing that point I'm
just saying it does not negate the fact
that he was bullied and arrested does
not negate the fact that his wife had to
contend with racism and it is not the
gate the fact that he has the right as
an individual to defend himself when he
feels aggrieved don't throw the baby out
the bath while this is the second time
I've talked no no I don't mean it
absolutely has the right the question
can I just touch from the point of
evidence because you said it so many
times it's only a value point I have to
make forgive me thank you very much for
his so in terms of the evidence you're
right don't overdue
way too friendly for me
right so in terms of the evidence right
we already know that they have
backpedaled we already know that they
didn't uh disclose certain bits of
information pertaining to the racism
claims however the absence of evidence
is not evidence of absence so when in
doubt rely on the balance of probability
what is the likelihood that an
institution sleeps in centuries of
colonialism and oppression of others
including the Irish Welsh and Scottish
Nations could continue to perpetuate I'm
afraid that if we look at the fact that
Queen Elizabeth
in the 1960s within the institution that
is institutionalization Tottenham
Hospital
won the league in 1961. they've never
won it since Arsenal playing them on
Sunday they're very unlikely to win it
again my point being you can go back to
anything in history
example something happened there they're
going to do it again balance the
probability
whatever whatever uh James you've
written a great book it's called an
approach without caution I think I
wouldn't approach you because you're a
massive unit it's the five-step plan to
take control of your life looks like
Harry could do with reading this or when
you said please James come on my show
and boost my ratings I thought you're
going to [ __ ] the book we're talking
about Harry my book's way more
interesting it's all factually been
checked as well um no look I think
what's the central point the point about
this is particularly in this case I
think it's great for you know some cores
are worth fighting for some some aren't
I think especially in 2023 everyone's
got to worry about everyone else's
business everybody is after everyone
else everyone's got a comment very
judgmental and I think if you're on a
path of self-development which everyone
should be stop looking over the garden
fence at what other people are doing you
know we're very critical of other people
we comment we get you know like I've
seen you interview lots of people who
partly pseudo Crusades glue themselves
to yeah motorways and doing whatever
thinking they're making a profound
difference because a lot of the time
it's an excuse for not looking at their
own you know deficiencies and how they
can improve themselves and I think for
me I wrote a couple of other books and
one of the themes that came out it was
I've had many epitfalls some some of you
were involved in yeah
[Laughter]
we ran it his mom was Furious it's never
too late to apologize I'm sorry now
we're best for friends everywhere he's
gonna put my book number one but but I
think a lot of the idea is about taking
charge and and some of the feedback I
got from the books was how I dealt with
with um the misfortunes pressure success
and failure um dealing with the media
and also some of the stuff around
Council culture and stuff like that you
know the example that you you've seen
when you lost the the John GMB how
people are so rattled about things when
if you were to look at those people in
division and go look are you better
coming after peers are you probably
worried about getting yourself healthier
yeah fitter totally agree and so some of
the some of the guys I'm in a new year
new peers thing at the moment no alcohol
eating healthily working out all the
time shredding the weight getting the
guns going so I'm gonna like the next
phase of new peers new New Years is this
read it I'm gonna go and read this and I
I've heard good things about it I think
you I like I love the podcast you do
thank you uh and it's great to see you
thank you and you haven't hit me so we
can move on now yeah and there's new
spirit of cooperation even you'll be
nice to this oh yeah all very
discombobulating thank you very much
James Haskell approach with that caution
the five-step plan take control of your
life excellent excellent book I'm told
by those in Reddit uh well next tonight
Harry claims to be a feminist married to
one of the walls leading feminists he
trashes Camilla mocks a disabled matron
whacks his sister-in-law feminist
and me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back to Facebook and assistant my
younger brother just message me to say
that I was actually on holiday when that
James Haskell story ran in the Daily
Mirror you remembered it so I'm off the
hook so I may have to withdraw my
apology to Mrs Haskell the mum uh but
actually I'll take responsibility
because I take accountability when
you're the boss you're the boss right so
I'll I'll take that on for the team
um well Prince Harry says he's a
feminist uh so in his own words here's
how he talks about women from his
mother-in-law to be disabled matron at
his school
you wrote I even wanted Camila to be
happy maybe she'd be less dangerous if
she was happy
how is she dangerous because of the need
for her to rehabilitate her image that
made her dangerous that made her
dangerous because of the connections
that she was forging within the British
press I want to sort of just briefly
talk about your stepmother and press
because you you were pretty consistently
scathing and suggest that you are
scathing
well scaling towards well as in you say
that your interests were sacrificed on
her PR altered I think in the book is
very clear what happened there's no part
of any of the things that I've said are
scathing towards any member of my family
especially not my stepmother unlike the
other matrons Pat wasn't hot that was
called that was small walking was hard
stairs were torture she descend
backwards glacially
often we stand on the landing below her
doing antique dances making faces
do I need to say which boy did this with
the most enthusiasm we went on mocking
her as she came down the stairs the
reward was worth the risk
for me the reward wasn't tormenting poor
Pat but making my mates laugh who the
hell is this editor
loathsome toad I gathered
everyone who knew her was in full
agreement that she was an infected
posture on the ass of humanity plus
excuse for a journalist
now that is happens to be a good friend
of mine uh and yeah not a nice way to
speak about a woman right especially
someone who gets so uptight when people
use that kind of language about his wife
well joining me now is journalist and
friend of Camilla page another Wyatt the
son's Royal photographer friend of
everybody Arthur Edwards and the
journalist and historian Dr Tessa Dunlop
oh let me start with you because you've
covered the Royals for longer than I've
been alive sorry not quite it's sort of
jumped that one only 40 years
um you know them you've known them all
very very well what what do you make of
this this book and the interviews around
it well I've you know I'm pretty
disgusted the way they said about
Camilla because uh she is just the
nicest person and you know when she
married the prince
he risked everything for that there was
a lot of hostility towards him over
there but you know what she just got
aired down and worked and worked and
worked I remember those early jobs with
her she was so nervous but she kept
trying try and try and then in the end
people got to love her because they
found what a really nice person she is
and Harry just trashing her like that I
was so I really wanted a smack him one
you know I thought it was an awful thing
to do is she's been nothing but nice to
him I remember once when he you know I
think it was 2000 2017 and he made some
stupid mistakes a statement about he
didn't want to be remember the real
family anymore
and I remember talking to her about the
next day she said you know he's such a
lovely boy Camilla all she said was how
nice he was you know speaking listen
I've known Camila a long time she comes
from the next door Village to me I've
known her a long time in her family
they're incredibly nice people very down
to earth very normal I had lunch with
the uh this now Infamous lunch with
Jeremy Clarkson was at this before
Christmas uh she was utterly delightful
to everyone and I don't think she
deserves this would be called a
dangerous villain by by Prince Harry as
we head towards a coronation where her
and Charles are gonna you know be
crowned our king and queen of this
country I just felt was so damaging and
unnecessary Tessa defend it I just would
like as it's all about truth and
accuracy I'm not sure he called her a
dangerous villain a villain and
dangerous no he explained that she was
the villain of the peace because she was
The Other Woman slightly taken out of
context in fact that line it just just
but he knows what he's right he knows
when he writes those things that'll be
the headline
you're crediting him with High um
intelligence and I think Harry used to
do things I don't think he's stupid
actually I don't think anyone will
accuse it I think he has a high EQ High
ego and we're seeing the full blast of
it right now what about the way he
generally talks about women just can we
just pick up on the Camilla thing and
what you two have both said that she's
Charming that you know she's the woman
next door literally for you the village
next door that she does have this very
natural way she's comfortable in her
skin she fits in she gets on with it she
loves the Gin she loves the [ __ ] we all
love Camilla do you know when that
replaces your dead mother and when you
feel like an outsider
his mother died in 1997. well now 2022
he's nearly 40 years old all right
they're just there comes a title it's
2023. there comes a time when you just
have to not move on and forget your
mother but actually accept your father's
very happy with the woman be married to
for 17 years why would you try and ruin
her reputation in the run-up to the
coronation I think there's probably
aspects of jealousy where she has
managed to rehabilitate Her Image and
interestingly she's done that in Britain
she hasn't successfully done that in
other Realms or indeed within the
Commonwealth where things are much
thinner ice and Charlie it hasn't been
given the chance it is therefore his
point stands really that this I don't it
is about her ability to work alongside
the Press of which both of you two are
significant players sure so at that
point stands now it's after his
relationship with his stepmother only
they know the real truth don't they and
we're in
she will never respond to any of this
that's why I feel sorry for all the
rules because they're trapped now with
this hand grenade going on the thing is
like Camilla had to endure
such vicious attacks from the press and
a level of violence from the public that
Megan
um
it was never even close I remember when
Camilla had bread rolls
it was not true well she said it's not
true maybe it wasn't but there was she
really was at one point the most hated
woman in Britain and Diana who was much
clever with the press and was younger
and More Beautiful well Donna learn to
work with the media I mean she used to
work exactly
but the point is that Camilla never
trained no she never skied I mean I've
known her since I was like she's
incapable of trying to be nice lady let
me ask you on a wider point about the
way that he talks about other women in
this book and in particular not just
taking down his sister-in-law which he
does I mean revealing text messages
after his wife Susan newspaper for
revealing contents of a letter from her
father the brass neck of Harry to then
reveal text messages without the consent
of Kate in his book to make money yes
but what struck me is the tordiness of
the book
um the sexual aspects which you might
mounting older women you might expect
that from a reality TV even the
Kardashians you don't expect to remember
the royal family and it is very sexist
it's very different and the stuff about
this poor matron Pat Jones she has a
name Pat Jones she was the matron at
Love Grove School he calls her greasy he
calls her ugly none of the boys got
horny when they saw she had a spinal
deficiency which he mocked and did it in
person he mocked the way did he defend
any of that oh why does he have to talk
about todgers
how can he can he take down his matron I
want to make two points one to answer
your specific question on the matron
that is Preparatory School mentality oh
really yeah I mean I think they should
be confined to the dust why would you
put it in a book guess what it has been
written why when you're supposed to be a
great feminist why would you why would
you annihilate innocent woman we don't
even know if she's alive or not but well
the her family are brothers but this was
probably something she talked about I I
was amazing just hang on it was written
now it was not written we've got to take
a short break short break uh timeout a
couple of minutes we'll be back hold
your passion there everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Cliffhanger so Tessa you want to say
something I feel a degree of sympathy
when
stories are taken from the book They're
dumped out they'll show greasy hair and
show you the Twisted spine and she was
this awful Old Toad and we all mocked
her but actually it was quite poetic
that piece it wasn't poetry it was nasty
wait let me finish my piece
it ends up the payoff is actually the
great joy for this boy who's just lost
his mother is to make all the kids laugh
and then and I'm going what would we do
for himself
wait let me read the line I loved
cracking my mates up but nothing quite
did it for me like making the otherwise
miserable Pat bastard guy right
she laughed too she knows
she wouldn't be laughing at a
description of herself in the fastest
selling book of in history of being
greasy ugly
I thought it was totally I'm sorry I
think it's totally it is a servant she
had to laugh she had no choice jumping
is the Rose between two Thorns The Thorn
Between Two Roses I think uh well I I
look going back to Harry I mean so he
was saying about Camilla using the media
no one used it more than Harry right I
mean we we went everywhere in the world
with him and he was found fantastic and
remember at the end of the day we'd all
go to the pub and we'd have a drink with
him and
and he would get it all off his chest
but you know he used to say to us I do
my best to give you great pictures every
day I want to get in the paper you know
get it in the paper get these promote
these causes of them
spot that I'm picturing a patron of he
was brilliant so you know having to go
about Camilla doing exactly the same
thing no it's just the brass necklace
I'm sorry I just read that book I put it
down this guy is just a spoiled entitled
victimhood
so he is also I think deeply unhappy
because they're happy so unhappy does
not write that kind of book he knows
it's going to hurt and a self-proclaimed
protector women's reputations and
someone who objected to anyone who
suggested that Megan Google the royal
family or somehow scheme to marry into
it says um that Camilla scheme to marry
Charles and become Queen consulate I
think we're all losing sight of the
bigger picture I hear peace in tone on
your love understandable love for the
monarchy here we have Andrew Edwards MBE
assists Arthur Edwards
about the roles in The Spectator
regularly you're passionate Royal it's
more so than me I'm also a royalist by
the way but if we want this institution
to survive it's no good getting in
behind our bunker and going go away
everyone else
what we're saying what we're saying all
right imagine for a moment imagine now
that William does his version he's not
going to exactly Kate does hers uh
Camilla does that the royal family would
collapse there would be no royal family
there'd be no monarchy they would be
sent off to some part of Europe and
that'd be the last we'd ever see them
like every other molecule virtually in
Europe right so we have one of the last
great monarchies and that's why I care I
care when this little Renegade duo in
California I'm making hundreds of
millions of dollars spray gunning this
family and the institution whilst
trading off the Royal titles they've
been used I think he's totally
disgusting yes and they're not giving
charity
let me bring an author you
it's a lovely book it's behind the crowd
my life photographing the royal family
you're a very interesting piece
defending Camilla in the summer you also
made a point you don't want to
photograph
Harry and Megan miserable I mean they
just didn't want to know you're done
with that oh I I I didn't do the picture
of South Africa you can go to uh
Australia I just um I find working with
them is so miserable they just didn't
want to help you in any way they they
wouldn't I mean they wouldn't do simple
things like hit a ball or nothing
anything you know where Catherine and
William would do all that the prince
look here's the deal with the Royals
right they survive through the patronage
of the British public and that is fueled
by the British media which Harry used to
test so much he can call us a bunch of
liars as much as he likes what's
interesting about the book is how many
stories appear in it where he confirms
what the media reported at the time
which were condemned a lot of the time
as lies the worrying thing is the
predominantly right-wing media and I'm
going to include you I'm not right-wing
don't you saying
most of the people at the moment
supporting the royal family tack hard to
the right
absolutely
mirrors
it's the working-class people in this
country who Revere the royal family and
many of them vote labor I know that
because I was headed to the mirror yeah
they were our readers and they love them
you managed to hold it together
reasonably long but in the end
light Harry complete claptrap Arthur
great book behind the crown my live
photographing the royal family great to
see you I know you've had a tough time
and it's really great to see you thank
you
what's this Harry in his underwear
tell me next what on Earth is the BBC
paying
giving this loathsome terrorist lover
such a massive platform a taxpayers
expense I've drove on my pack to discuss
that this lot will carry on Charlie I'll
have to wait for the other team will
look at that pack
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
making a rare Regal visit Daily Mirror
Associated to Kevin McGuire talk TV
contributor Esther crack well welcome to
all of you happy New Year
um let's start with you okay about this
unbelievably abhorrent excuse for a
human being Andrew bridgen MP who who
tweeted a load of Claptrap about the
Kobe vaccines and so there's one
consultant cardiologist said to me this
is the biggest crime against humanity
since the Holocaust and that came after
a number of other ludicrous tweets he
did about covid and vaccines and so on
and that was the Tipping Point where
he's now had his whip suspended what's
going to happen to this guy how can you
have a serving Member of Parliament
expressing such views well there are
lots of people in his own party and
Beyond it now who want to see that he
won't stand at the next election because
this has been going on not just for a
couple of weeks but a couple of months
on a scale he's been talking about some
of the data around some of the rare
effects of covert vaccination and
manipulating that data or
misrepresenting it perhaps for the last
couple of months and then things have
stepped up recently and it's been
causing some real worry in his party and
you're right that the Tweet you just
read out there is the Tipping Point you
know what I think may be the problem
you've got a picture here this is of the
same Andrew bridge in having his
coverage yeah and I think what's
happened is his worst fears came true
that he got injected with the vaccine it
planted a chip in his brain that turned
him into an utter [ __ ] and that is a
terrible side effect of the vaccine
Kevin yeah which we weren't aware of
until we read his tweets now look he
he I think he's finished now I don't
think the Tories will have you've just
gone nuts he never used to be this mad
did he no and what's happened is he's
lost a big uh civil case with his
brother he's gonna have to pay something
like a million quid in
costs and um
no no no I agree but he's there now
until the general election yeah I don't
think he'll be after that but no it's
ridiculous the other hot story shamima
Bagan right so this is an ongoing story
of this she was 15 when she went off to
live with an Isis terrorist had three
babies with his Isis terrorist he would
come back having beheaded people stuff
heads in bins and so on uh I've got no
time for it whatsoever I don't think she
should be allowed back into this country
she's just stay in the Terra bed she
made for herself out there for a number
of years she's now staggeringly been
given this like eight part podcast on
the BBC a taxpayer expense called I'm
not a monster basically explaining why
she's you know perfectly decent human
being you should be allowed to come back
I think you're right most British people
don't have time for shimmy Bigham or any
other terrorist that decided to go out
there and do what she did I think the
question is why is the BBC the national
broadcaster that we are forced to pay
for co-signing this and why are they
trying to it's not just a short
interview isn't it why are they trying
to rehabilitate the image to what to
whatever why do we need this but it's
not about Rehabilitation it's about it's
about a woman who in Britain has become
a poster girl for Isis
look she could be a threat to National
Security but she is our problem and I
think the government was wrong because
she's British and for us to say because
her parents were born in Bangladesh are
you saying they were are you saying to
all the same to all Second Generation
[Music]
Um migrants in Britain that we might
take you out but I don't think I don't
think any I don't think anything well I
don't think any Isis terrorists who were
born in Britain should be allowed back
if they went off to commit terrorism
there's about 350 the government have
allowed to come back and not jump well I
have used her as a poster a poster girl
to make it look why should we let her
become a celebrity she was 50 she was
50. so that's not an excuse me she was
15. that is not an excuse she was 15 she
was groomed and she was trafficked she
was underage for sex and married off
yeah
she had sex for four years with the guy
he was coming back from beheading people
agree with some people if a group had
radicalized that and done this to her
and with her in Swansea or Sunderland or
Sterling rather than Syria okay she
would be in the care of Social Services
what's the Kate McCann view of this well
I think the fact that you're arguing
about it so intensely says that actually
there is an argument to say some
journalism could be done here now the
tone of this podcast is going to be
absolutely everything is it going to be
all about trying to get sympathy for her
or is it actually interrogating what's
happened here and listening to the
journalist who is behind this podcast
there is some question now about what he
is exposing and whether that could
actually harm the appeal process that
she's currently in because she is
appealing the decision to revoke her
citizenship she's not been allowed to
come back to the UK to do that but it
was only recently heard a few months ago
and there are some who say the fact that
she does talk about I did travel I made
these decisions myself might undermine
the case that she's making that she was
trafficked and there's a whole other
element about a Canadian spy involved
here and it's complex but I think
shining a light on it is only going to
help okay interesting point quick
question about the strikes I I listen
I've got a lot of sympathy with people
who are really on the breadline working
in in these industries who are striking
I get it they can't all get inflation
pay rise it will go bust as a country
what I didn't like today were the
ambulance workers the scenes of them all
looking like they were celebrating you
know all coming out dancing and cheering
and people tooting hey I was like what
are they celebrating I mean if they came
out looking serious and like this was an
awful thing they were compelled to do
they might get my support I can't
support them cheering as people might be
dying yeah but look people are dying
every day because of the state so why
let more down the state of the ambulance
service but they feel they've watched
the service they work in and they care
about being run down and also their
their wages
you wouldn't be able to sell they care
very much about it with the celebrating
this is the next this is a peer disaster
that's the issue a lot of people have
sympathy for them but when you do this
you kind of Lose Yourself don't come out
singing and dancing I think he's all
right great to have the royal visit
please don't leave it as long we like
having it Kevin good to see you that's
it great to see you again because he put
the yards in over here
that's it for me tonight what are you up
to Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you